worth of taiwan is back worth it chicken
is that a chicken yeah i know it's a
rooster which is a chicken
is that a chicken no it's a pigeon here
at tainan's garden night market we've
just picked up our chicken treats
tomorrow the journey begins
we're going to three cities for three
acts of chicken ending in a chicken
finale like you've never seen before
bok bok bish lego
mmm it's like a pancake today i'm worth
it we're gonna be trying three chicken
dishes at three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
the most worth it at its price
so we're eating chicken but our first
chicken is actually a soup i know we
just finished a soup video but that's
just how many soups there are here
you can't escape the soup we're off to
see the chen family at
walking sioux where we're going to be
trying their sesame oil chicken
what is that in mandarin inca mayo
my own
okay i'm excited to eat some chicken
let's do it
tell us about how this business got
started
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this looks incredible we've got a couple
additional
accoutrement here the thai basil sauce
the spicy fermented bean paste and
sticky rice
all right let's taste the broth sesame
oil
chicken
delightful nuttiness of this sesame oil
yeah
super nutty super got this hearty feel
to it
oh yeah this is hearty ass
how's that oh it's so incredibly juicy
and tender and
i'm gonna smell the thai basil because
that's our specialty here
[Music]
whoa smells like pesto yeah
what that is awesome that is like a
salad dressing to dip your soup into
adam you gotta try the chicken in the
thai basil
i'm gonna try some rice oh yes chicken
steven
the thing i keep getting blown away by
in taiwan i go to a meal expecting one
thing and then there's
always all this bonus stuff that just
blows my expectations out of the water
yeah i mean even when they first started
this restaurant
this was a bonus dish right this one
that's crazy
thing so there's a lot of herbs added to
this soup tastes like an elixir
it just washes away all the pain on your
body achy back
i got a soup for that tired eyes soup
for that
my foot hurts throw some soup on there
it's all the same soup it's very
convenient
adam you want to get some of this soup
i'm pretending like adam's over here
even though he's over there right
so our next chicken location is in
taipei
but first we're going to take a
countryside detour yeah that's right
we're going to a scallion farm in ilan
and we're going to be making our own
scallion pancakes
not just cooking them we're going to
pick them ourselves scallions
yeah it's a chicken episode it's a soup
episode and now it's a pancake episode
[Music]
what you see in front of you here is a
scallion pancake but
rewind three hours what did we do we're
in this unique
valley where you get different
temperature winds at different times of
day
which create a nice perfect humidity for
growing scallions
so today we've picked a bunch of
scallions cleaned them up chopped them
cried a little bit and then learned how
to make scallion pancakes
and here we have it the spoils of our
toils cheers
oh no
mmm okay this is one of the best things
i've eaten so far
you know what time it is now time for a
taiwan food fact
the concept of xiaochu meaning little
eats is popular in taiwan
basically meaning snacking throughout
the day often on street food
between meals of course yeah in taiwan
if you only eat three meals in one day
you're just doing it wrong
we're actually on our way to a snack
shop next pinko where are we going
uh chuza we're gonna see reebok and
julia and try their fried chicken
what makes a perfect fried chicken to
you guys
[Music]
what this is not what i was expecting
you ready stephen i'm ready
this is called dining al fresco
so we've ordered the recommended
sparkling wine apparently
you only order by the bottle here i like
that let's go
high speed cheers
[Music]
how awesome is this this is some riviera
we gotta eat this while it's hot so
let's go
oh it's so fragrant the garlic the onion
this basil
the meat inside is so soft it was very
pleasing
very pleasing like bruleed marshmallow
seriously
oh man that's wild i thought kufu was a
one for dumplings
[Music]
you're so soft it's almost like chicken
nugget-esque
you know what's crazy about this we've
eaten fried chicken in minneapolis
where the restaurant thought you know
what's actually the best drink to have
with fried chicken
sparkling wine and here we are in taiwan
and this restaurant i had the same idea
i see if there's a restaurant
on either side of the world that is
doing the same thing it must be great
i'm scared to eat this because i'm
scared of how much i like it pork
knuckle
and radish cake wow
[Music]
oh man watch out they're gonna push me
off my stool radish take is a plastic
dim sum dish i've eaten this like
every time i go out you know they bring
around the carton like they're all
steamed right
it's still hot but it doesn't have that
like break through the crunch
texture that this has you can maybe
liken it to
a potato pancake that's so good that's
crazy
how should we eat the pork knuckle by
hand
by hand just like an apple mm-hmm okay
kind of looks like a doughnut oh yours
does mine does
cheers
oh oh my god this is like a pork donut
wow so this is actually cartilage
but it feels like that with how
loosey-goosey it is
the gelatin oh the jelly of this pork
donut
right and to wash it down sparkling wine
oh thank goodness for this
how awesome is this thank you this is
really good
we are at the regent hotel where they
serve a
boba croissant yes you heard me write
boba
croissant we got the matcha
tiramisu and the milk tea which one do
you want my gut is going toward matcha
but i'm going against my gut and go for
the tiramisu i actually knew that you
were gonna pick that one because it has
gold flake on it
all right i'll go milk tea very
satisfying to pick up
cheers cheers are you gonna bite into it
yeah or open it up
i'm gonna bite into it
[Music]
this is just all of the textures it's
nice it's like
satisfyingly squishy i think that's a
word for that qq
ready for a taiwan food pack stephen
it's one food fact
taiwan food fact um
up until the 1960's the most common
taiwanese breakfast was
rice or congee buns emerged as a popular
taiwanese food in the 1960s when u.s
trade introduced wheat into the
taiwanese diet
shouldn't that fact go in the dumpling
episode that we did well it's more about
breakfast i
just wanted an excuse to talk about
kanji because it's just a nice
savory thing to have for breakfast this
is
a very good croissant yeah
i got a cake oh my this boba croissant
is part of a
boba festival bubbling here at the
region and inca's got
the uh crown jewel of the festival and
now it's time to take
a little train ride qq
don't hear my boba wrap yeah how do you
like your boba
yeah eat it like a cobra yeah my name is
yoda
yeah and i like yoga
now dab never this is a trained water
bottle that they sell on the tray
so once we get done with this guy we'll
be in taichung and we'll be eating at
our final
chicken location we're going to go meet
shiraba at mo
to have beggar's chicken
[Music]
what kind
which one of us gets to do it i'll do
the hammering you do hammer time what
you just automatically assume that you
get the hammer
you can both do it yeah okay okay two
hammers yeah
okay results
oh thank you
cheers to our final meal in taiwan oh
no no cheers
since this is our last meal in taiwan
we're blowing it out let's do it i saw a
little sneak peek of what's coming
upstairs
it's gonna blow you away so this is
winter melon whoa
wow wow
[Music]
what look at it coming out pouring on
the fish's head
these look too real look at the scales
on these guys
honestly every time i've seen a koi fish
i thought they look like a tasty fish
cheers steven fish kiss
this is from the dumpling oh
super good this looks like in hook when
robin williams is imagining the food
have you seen this movie it's all like
vibrant colors
do yourself a favor go watch hook you'll
have a delightful time you'll be
reminded of this moment
i'm going pink for my hair
we might as well have just shot all
three episodes here
much like the origin myth first we're
eating like
an emperor and then we're taking a
journey to discover the chicken
food is all about storytelling and taste
but also storytelling
[Music]
oh hey okay
what fiesta what
you guys can go up now summertime okay
all right steven
i'm nervous i am scared too one
two three wow nice
looks like chocolate smells like
dirt we just hatched our chicken dinner
it is very dino egg like
[Music]
um
wow chicken cheers chicken cheers
oh that's good what that is so soft
some people say chickens are boring me i
would say those people haven't had it
deep fried bacon clay stuffed with pork
and aromatics
there's pork in the chicken yeah so now
she's just adding like a sauce i think
it's like an oyster sauce slurry
oh that tastes
like my mom's fried rice whoa that's
weird
mom you know what this chicken is it's a
time capsule
for flavor buried under dirt much like a
regular time capsule but it's also
a dish from the main dynasty is there a
letter written in there
like dear diary do i still taste good
very soft at its core this dish is just
a plate of really nice chicken so simple
so perfect
we're gonna take it back into artistry
land now if that's okay with you
let's do it what is going on yeah right
now
yeah dude
looks like a scene from nightmare before
christmas this is too beautiful not to
share i think we should get everybody in
here and we all take a bite who wants a
swan who wants a pumpkin
cheers everybody cheers
what oh my god
it's a red bean why wow
why not why why not
worth it beggars chicken you know they
say beggars can't be choosers but
beggars can be chicken that was quite an
experience stephen before we get to our
worth at winners
what was your favorite thing that wasn't
one of the highlight foods
in this worth it episode the pork
knuckle at chuja's
the southern it was so good i
contemplated eating my own knuckles
what was your favorite thing honestly
the hard ass rain
while we were filming location two we
had a typhoon barely graze us but we
still got some awesome hard rain which i
love
which chicken was the most worth it to
you my worth at winner
walking sioux sesame oil chicken if that
chicken had been in the soup episode
it would have won that episode too wow
comforting exciting
inexpensive it was wonderful who's your
worthy winner okay
walking sue totally new experience yeah
if you could eat with your eyes that
place would have won but because that
pork knuckle was so
effing good my worth it winner must go
too
[Music]
oh the fried chicken very good choice
all right that's a wrap on worth of
taiwan
very special thank you to the taiwan
tourism bureau that helped us out
tremendously with this trip
couldn't have been here without them all
right let's get out of here
bye
[Music]
you